hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
quality control for the pharmaceutical
industry
stage 3 continued verification in the
life cycle
of analytical procedures i'm susie
valdez of labyrinth and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes
and brought to you by sartorius to learn
more visit
sartorius.com so let's get started
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
also please notice that you can share
this webinar
on your personal social media just click
on the social sharing tab
to let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation simply click
on the support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left
of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus
offers continuing education credits tab
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker jane
whitefield
jane whitefield is an independent
consultant and has been working in
analytical chemistry for over
40 years for the pharmaceutical and
mining company
she's currently a consultant
specializing in laboratory management
systems
gmp testing and iso iec
17025 she is an auditor
and an educator and jane has applied
quality systems
in statistical techniques including the
evaluation and use of measurement
uncertainty
in a wide variety of technical
scientific
businesses she's obtained the american
society
of quality certification for both
quality
engineer and quality manager for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
jane welcome you may now begin your
presentation
well good day and welcome to this
webinar on analytical quality control
for the pharmaceutical
industry
this webinar is going to focus on stage
3
continued verification in the life cycle
of analytical procedures
this is the stage that really the
quality control laboratories use
i just want to first state that this
presentation is
my perspective and not that of any other
organization
so the topics that we're going to cover
today are
dealing with the analytical quality
control
now it's for pharmaceutical drugs
especially as it relates to lab
instruments
the weighing pipetting hblc sample
preparation
and we'll go all through all of these in
our example
we'll briefly describe the life cycle
approach to analytical procedures
the background for this stage 1
development stage 2 qualification
where the analytical control strategy is
developed
and finally we'll go through the routine
use of the procedure in the qc
laboratory
using the knowledge from stages one and
two using
that analytical control strategy
quality control laboratories are
critical
their role is to demonstrate the
pharmaceutical products are consistently
manufactured
safe potent and pure now at the same
time
the number of tests run by qc
laboratories is increasing
labs have no resources to waste
the life cycle approach to analytical
procedures
and the analytical control strategy from
that
allow qc laboratories to be efficient
and ineffective and i just want to say
i've worked for this
a number of years and i am impressed
with how this life cycle approach
really does emphasize efficiency and
effectivity
that's really an excellent business
strategy
as well
now the usp has provided a number of
resources
and there is a list that is available as
a downloadable file for you
there is a number of stimuli articles
and supporting articles
and official general chapters so i
encourage you to go and read these
if you haven't already after this
webinar
today we are going to focus on
analytical control strategy
as described in this usp
stimuli article that you can find in
uspf425
this is really relevant to qc labs
because you use the analytical control
strategy
what's the life cycle approach the
analytical control
strategy provided by that approach
is a key tool to ensure the analytical
procedures are
working as expected the laboratory is
not wasting time monitoring
variables that are not important the
sources of variability are adequately
controlled
what is the life cycle approach the life
cycle management process
provides a framework for defining the
criteria for
and development of an analytical
procedure that meets those acceptance
criteria
the procedure then becomes part of a
continuous verification
cycle to demonstrate that it meets these
pre-defined criteria
over the life of the procedure
implementation throughout the procedures
life cycle of a change
management process that is based on
knowledge
gained during the procedures lifetime
ensures that the procedure remains
fit for its intended use
and that fit for its intended use is
important
we'll see that more and more and more
this
and how do you define that intended use
is all explained in the life cycle
approach
now key to the general approach is an
understanding of overall variability
including variability arising from the
analytical procedure
so this figure shows the life cycles and
its stages stage 1
procedure design and development stage 2
procedure performance qualification
and that used to be called method
validation
and stage 3 is that continued procedure
performance verification
which comes in the qc laboratory which
routinely runs the method
notice that that box on its side and the
right
risk assessment now risk assessment and
risk is a really
key topic nowadays you see it in all
kinds of guides
and knowledge management no point doing
something learning if you don't manage
that knowledge
and the analytical control strategy is a
tool for managing that knowledge
and so these are the stages and we'll
suppose
uh emphasize stage three in this talk
now said picture and purpose fit for you
fit for intended use all these phrases
for pharmaceuticals that means the
intended use is linked to the clinical
requirement
and here we see three arrows
representing the measurement uncertainty
of what well look when they do a
clinical study they find out the
concentrations
that they need to use of the drug well
they manufacture the drug and you've got
to make sure that that
is within the concentration used in
clinical so
manufacturing has to manufacture to a
smaller
range then that's tested in the lab
and the lab has to test to an even
smaller range to make sure
that the drug is fit for its intended
use
so this little picture just shows how
fit for intended use work
now with the life cycle approach is the
analytical target profile the atp
it's a predefined objective that states
the performance requirements for the
analytical procedure
and the output of the procedure is a
reportable result
that must be fit for its purpose so in
that previous slide
that was the laboratory and that small
arrow for measurement of certainty
good method has to meet that requirement
to be fit for purpose
and this applies throughout the life of
the analytical procedure
well the analytical charter profile it
includes the target measurement
uncertainty
and that is back to that picture with
the clinical the manufacturing
laboratory that's the size of that arrow
how
big can the uncertainty be and the
analytical results still be good for you
that's the target for human uncertainty
along with the atp tells you the
probability
and it gives the acceptable probability
of being wrong
so you know risk analysis has been
working it's all really around
probability
how do you define a risk how do you
quantify it
it's through probability and the atp
provides you an acceptable probability
of being wrong
so as long as your method is smaller
than that you're okay
it's fit for you now these three little
pictures on this slide
that represents the normal distribution
of reportable values
and it's not an hplc chromatogram it's
not a peak
it's a normal distribution curve and it
shows that there are this range of
possible
values from an analytical result
so that bottom little chart with the
green
check mark beside it that's a good one
you've got the limits you've got the
the result as well within those limits
the normal distribution is just within
the limits you've got a
negligible probability of being wrong
it's less than 0.00
well you look at the top little norman
distribution curve on the right side
with that red x beside it well there's a
bias there
and it has a large probability of being
wrong turns out to be over six percent
which is
not usually acceptable so you don't want
that
and the bottom on the right well there
there's a huge uncertainty associated
with that value the range within which
the true value could probably be
is too big
and so that's not acceptable
and so that's how the analytical target
profile
relates to target measurement and
certainty so ideally in the qc
lab you want that green check mark a
distribution curve and you want to
verify it continues to perform like that
how is the atp worded i find this is
useful
so for an assay and we're going to give
an example of an assay
so the procedure that's the analytical
procedure your test method
must be able to quantify the analyte
in presence of whatever that matrix is
over a range of a to b percent and you
define that
of the nominal concentration within
accuracy and uncertainty
so that the reportable result falls
within plus or minus c percent of that
true value
with at least p percent probability
now the variables in orange are specific
for each reportable result
and it's customized for each procedure
and each use of that procedure
and that c is the target measurement
uncertainty
now there's a law here we only have a
limited time i can't go into how you
calculate the target measurement and
certainty is but all those usp
papers have that but what we're going to
emphasize in this webinar here
today is how useful all this stuff is
so stage one procedure design and
develop a a procedure is needed well
somebody defines the fit for purpose
usually it's the pharmaceutical
technology group the r d
group they define the atp the target
measurement certainly the probability is
determined
and so they design and develop a
procedure they choose a technique
such as hplc and along with that what
they're doing their experiments on this
method they develop the analytical
control strategy
so if they find a potential source of
variability is significant
contributor to the measurement
uncertainty then a control is needed for
that
source
in stage two design and development
procedure performance
qualification well then
in this performance qualification which
actually used to be called method
validation
the analytical control strategy is
confirmed
and controlled strategy could be all
kinds of steps
uh system suitability trending control
charting providing a detailed training
to the analyst
including detailed instructions in your
test method and your operating
procedures
strict control of things like time or
temperature
specifying grades of materials or other
control mechanisms
these are all part of the analytical
controlled strategy that is confirmed
during that performance qualification
and most importantly the measurement
uncertainty is evaluated
in that qualification
knowledge management that's important
especially in
in stage two to capture the knowledge
from stage one
and from the qualification and that
document should be documented somewhere
preferably in a qualification
report important thing to the to that is
to document what is not known
so they've learned a lot of things about
the method but maybe they don't know
some things and it's important to
document that
this is really useful for qc
laboratories because they often have to
deal with that unknown
for example in the development
validation they could only use
one lottery agent because it was
expensive or
maybe only one lot was available well
that should be
documented only one lot was used
we don't know what will happen when you
change locks
and you mitigate the risk of using only
one lot
so the qc lab knows that when they you
have to use a new lot
they're going to have to do something
they're going to have to monitor more
closely
qualify new lot before using or on an
actual example or something
like that
knowledge management is very important
in the life cycle approach
knowledge management and risk are both
very important aspects of the life cycle
approach
i find often that labs have done some of
this but in
absence of a good system and
understanding it's it's isolated and
disjointed
and you'll notice that the guides the
fda guidances
and the requirements and the ich guides
are on talking about risk management
well how does this work for that
analytical procedure in the
life cycle this chart is taken from that
analytical control strategy paper that i
highlighted at the beginning
so you you use your prior knowledge your
expertise you develop and you do a risk
assessment you identify
potential sources of variability of risk
and you evaluate them
and then you saw how to control them are
you going to reduce them are you just
going to accept them what are you going
to do
and that becomes your control strategy
of course you do a regular risk review
and document that in your knowledge
management
it's the qc laboratory that's
responsible for the use and maintenance
of the risk management
during routine use of the method
and how do you do this well for an
analytical procedure
measurement uncertainty and its
evaluation
is how you manage the risk for that
reportable value
there's a lot of documents on how to
evaluate the measurement of certainty
and this webinar is not about that
but briefly we'll go through the process
so just a number of steps for evaluating
certainty
one you identify the measure around
which includes the analyte
and then you list the steps in your
analytical procedure
and from that you can identify potential
sources of the random variability in
each step
those are the uncertainty components and
you design a process that permits an
estimate of each
and then you combine them all together
and that's five to combine them all
together we'll see that
equation in our example
so uncertainty
is treated as a standard deviation this
is important to know a little bit about
statistics and we all have to learn this
now
and standard deviations are combined as
their variances they're squared
so the important thing is that if an
uncertainty component
pro uh fights less than a third of the
largest uncertainty component
it is not significant and there's the
equation standard deviations combined or
u
is the uncertainty combined so the
square root of the
sum of the squares
so as a reminder potential uncertainty
sources
are listed here and i think as a qc lab
person you're aware of these
and these are examples of potential
sources of uncertainty
so you use uncertainty to evaluate the
risk
you know water consequences the severity
of a risk
you evaluate that you determine directly
the combined contribution to uncertainty
using your method performance data now
these are the analytical procedure
development qualification experimental
values
for repeatability robustness
intermediate precision all those
that's key data that you use
and on from that stage one two the qc
lab is a recipient of this knowledge
and the risks and how to manage them
so just to summarize a little bit the
atp
defines what your requirements of that
reportable value what you're testing its
use
from that you're going to tell you the
critical quality control attributes for
an assay
method it would be accuracy and
precision
and that informs your target measurement
and certainty the highest uncertainty
you could have
and that report of the volume still be
fit for use
and so stage three continued performance
verification of your analytical
procedures that qc lab does
so in the continued verification
qc lab receives the analog control
strategy
and they use it it's important to have a
mechanism for the routine
monitoring of the performance of the
procedure and controlling changes to the
analytical procedure
and so that's how happens in in stage
three
now to go through this we're going to
give an example i always find examples
of the best way to learn and to
illustrate things
so we have the description of pvs for
example
we're going to use a drug substance test
for potency
one gram of drug substance is weight and
the concentration of the drug substance
is a thousand milligrams per gram
for if you're used to percent that's a
hundred percent i'm using milligrams per
gram because that's the proper
si units that should be used now
taylor for simplicity i'm not including
some uncertainty components
just for simplicity insert either bias
or long term
in a full proper evaluation those should
be included
so here's our method that we're using
for example
and it has the five steps weighing
extraction
pipetting solid preparation
and the hvlc measurement and notice here
there's two injections so there's two
chromatograms
and the reportable value is the average
of those two injections
that's our method remember
how you combine the uncertainty
components so we have five steps
if we determine the uncertainty from
each step we can combine them square
root of the sum of the squares
so during the design development stages
if they're well designed you can get the
uncertainty for each of those steps and
the nova is a very powerful term
and a tool for that we're not going to
go into that now
however it can be done you know
i often go into labs and i look at their
qualifications
and they have the data they just don't
do the anova
it's not that much work i encourage you
to learn about that
so from that proper nova analysis done
during stage one and two
it turns out that the uncertainties for
each of these steps is determined so
stage one
was two milligrams per gram stage two
sample extractions ten stage three
pipetting was
two in stage four the hplc solvent
preparation
it was determined that it it wasn't
didn't have any impact on the
uncertainty but you did have to control
the grade
so here is an example of where the
analytical control strategy
is to control the grade of that reagent
but there's no contribution to the
uncertainty
and step five the measurement now that's
the average of two injections with three
milligrams per gram
so you use the formula and notice that
it's certainties
it's one two three but none from step
four
and then step five so that is the
formula and if you calculate it
squaring them summing the squares and
taking the square root the combined
uncertainties
11 milligrams per gram so
just notice that
how is this useful well let's take a
simple little example
and say oh qc lab uses its magic wand
every lab has a
magic wand and what if you could remove
the impact of
all that variability from weighing so
there step one is zero
if you do that and you go through
you'll see that it has no impact on the
uncertainty
so improving your weighing step would
have no
improvement on your method so that's the
benefit of what you can learn
in the knowledge from the uncertainty
steps
also if you look at your balance and
your
calibration certificate and
uh sartorius very kindly provided this
one so we can look at it and you look
under i'm certainly
in use on this certificate it gives you
the uncertainty from the balance itself
so the first line is 1.2 grams we're
weighing one gram so it's uncertainty is
0.00022 grams
or 0.022 milligrams now this is an
expanded uncertainty
we'll see that next slide using a k of
two so the actual standard uncertainty
is point zero one
now this is much less than the two
milligrams so certainly for the example
so your actual balance and calibration
is not a major uncertainty
you can use this to know your balance is
capable and say if
it goes out of cal or something and
becomes .02 milligrams uncertainty
that has no impact and you can use that
in your assessment
of that balance so it's very useful
here we have look at another change with
this method
going back we've got our weighing
uncertainty in there
what about pipetting it's two milligrams
per gram
what is the impact of that
again looking at the calibration
certificate we can find out
our pipette how critical is it to our
pipetting
so you look at your calibration
certificate and there
and further on in the pages it says the
uncertainty budget was calculated
from the uncertainty associated with the
measuring process and it says
the reported expanded uncertainty budget
is a result from the standard
uncertainty
by multiplication of the coverage factor
k
equals 2. so to get the standard
uncertainty we know we have divide by
two so at 500 microliters on the
certificate
the expanded uncertainty is 0.63 so this
the standard uncertainty is 0.32
microliters
now our uncertainty is in micro in
milligrams per gram
so to compare the volume impact
to the weight i change it percent
both point zero six percent relative
and the two milligrams per gram
uncertainty for pipetting is
point two percent relative
so if you compare that point zero six to
point two it is
about a third it is significant
so the pipette that you're using is
important
so that pipette is significant portion
of the pipetting uncertainty and you
have to control it accordingly
so maybe you want to verify it
immediately before use
or maybe you want to calibrate it more
frequently
maybe you also want to train the
analysts on pipetting techniques
and there's a lot of courses in that and
the pipetting providers give these
courses
so that will help you standardize how
petting's done
and you can train the animals initially
and perhaps retrain unspecified
intervals
so this is an example of where the
training on the pipetting would be an
analytical control strategy to
control that pipette which is a
significant part
of the pipette uncertainty
i have seen labs do this when i directed
laboratories i
implemented some of these trainings and
you could measure the improvement and
the fewer os's post-training
the the control charts got tighter
it really was was very effective and
i've seen it when i audit labs as well
and so that's why it is a significant
component of the certainty
and it needs to be controlled
and finally let's talk about replication
the control strategy paper has a whole
appendix on replication it's an
important aspect well remember
that in our method we're taking
two readings has two chromatograms there
in step five and the uncertainty of that
the average of the two is three
milligrams
per gram well what happens
if we um if we only do
one injection we get one chromatogram
what would the uncertainty be well we're
very lucky that there is a formula the
reality in our universe the standard
error of the mean
where that standard mean is equal to the
standard deviation of an individual
result divided by
square root of n the number of
replicants
so for our example the standard error
the mean is three
and there's two replicas so the standard
deviation for doing one replica one
injection
is three times the square root of two
which is 4.2 milligrams per gram
and i've given you a reference for that
in the missed handbook
well here we have here's our method
we're only doing
one injection so now our uncertainty
from the measurement is 4.2 milligrams
per gram
and here we go remember what the
uncertainty was with two
ingestions it was 11 milligrams per gram
it's the same for one injection
there was no benefit for doing two
injections there's a lot of benefits for
doing one
you could change your analytical
procedure to use only one injection and
you've got
all the data and knowledge there to
demonstrate that your method is still
fit for its use it still meets the
requirements of the atp
but you as a qc lab are going to save
time and resources
and it's going to reduce the chance of
obtaining an os measurement
that's valuable
and something that often happens with
our example let's look at what if the qc
laboratory is asked to improve
manufacturing isn't happy with the
method somebody wants for qc lab to
improve this method
where should they look get 10 that
sample extraction remember it had 10
milligrams per gram contribution to the
uncertainty
so you could either improve the sample
extraction or
replicate at the sample extraction step
remember s divided by the square root of
n
and so here if you look at it if you
took two test portions all the way
through
and that means two injections at each
there of each sample prep
well each uncertainty is decreased by
40 percent square root of two so you can
see down below
and there the uncertainty combined
becomes
7.6 milligrams gram it's about 8
milligrams grams compared to the 11.
now this is a lot of extra work is it
worth it
is that decrease of 3 milligrams gram in
certainty around the reportable result
valuable
maybe you could do this and at the same
time change to one
injection for each sample prep that
would get rid of some work
and we know that would have no impact on
the 8
milligram per gram
so you decide but as a qc lab now you've
got
david and probability to decide what you
want to do
so looking at the analytical process
with its units
sample prep measurement and replicate
strategy
you can come up with control strategies
for each of these as we did that sample
prep
the measurements are you going to do one
or two injections with your replicate
strategy
and you can develop your control
strategy
so finally that quality risk management
process
all these requirements is a standard
risk management chart
for an analytical procedure you can use
the evaluation
and use of measurement uncertainty to
meet the requirements of this
identification of uncertainty components
determining what that impact is and
looking what you're going to do and
how are you going to reduc reduce that
with your analytical control strategy
so in conclusion
you can be efficient and effective
with your analytical procedure using the
life cycle approach
you're not going to waste time and
resources
and you can confidently defend the
performance of that
to any annual regulatory agency
and the test results will support
manufacturing they will be fit for use
step 3 continued procedure performance
verification
is for the quality control laboratory
that concludes this part of the
presentation and we are now
ready and open for live questions
and thank you jane for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located at the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for so
jane let's take a look
at the questions already coming in from
our live audience
what are all the common problems that qc
faces
ah thank you uh qc
can face a lot of problems and
common ones really when you
come down to an investigate you find out
that they weren't
told all the knowledge about the test
method
the analytical procedure maybe pharm
tech or
the r d group knew there was an issue
dealt with it but didn't communicate
that
so that is the source of a lot of
problems and that's why knowledge
management is important in the life
cycle
approach the other
another example is the control
strategies
not adequate often the uncertainty is
not evaluated correctly or at all
and it turns out that a
part of the method can have a huge
impact on the uncertainty and it's not
evaluated properly
and it's the qc lab that finds that out
and has to deal with it
and again the life cycle approach with a
control strategy
gives the qc lab the knowledge and
capability and tools to deal with those
so on a high level those are some of the
problems that a qc lab
faces
thank you so much jane and one of our
audience members wants to know
can you give us the exact differences
between
a cube a and a qc
okay quality q assure all right
qa is quality assurance and qc is
quality
control and the definition of
the difference between them often
depends on the industry
you're in in the pharmaceutical industry
they are very strictly
defined and the
fda and the cfr for example uses quality
control
to cover the whole quality field
including what's called quality
assurance
quality assurance in other industries is
the department that has the
responsibility and oversight for quality
for whatever the that company industry
is doing
and quality control is just the
laboratory
that does the testing and so those are
some of the differences between quality
assurance and quality control
thank you jane and again i want to thank
our audience for their questions
jane this next question is about
certification
should an analyst be able to prove that
they are
certified to verify instruments such as
balances and type pipe bits
the um that's an interesting question
i'm coming
from the the iso 17025 accreditation
world
with the new standard that came out in
2017
they called the analysts competent
and you have to demonstrate their
competency and you have to
authorize them to do an activity
and so if an analyst is going to be
verifying a balance or
verifying a pipette you have the qc
lab manager has to make sure that that
person knows what they're doing
and can do it and they have to provide
adequate training and they have to at
some point
authorize the person to do that there's
many
ways of doing that that are very
practical but they have to be
authorized yes
thank you and gene do you think a
biochemist
has the capacity to become a qc
um yes often the people who work in
quality control labs come from very many
different fields
and i for example was a classically
trained
inorganic chemist doing fire assay in
the mining industry and was able to
transfer to a quality control lab and
pharmaceutical
with no problem again referring to the
previous statement
question and answer about the competency
of the analyst
with the qc lab they should have the
proper system to
make sure their analysts are competent
and along with that would be reviewing
they could be the the skills
education training of the person often
in biochemistry they have some lab work
and some knowledge
and so that would be applicable to
becoming a qc
person thank you and
accused also the analysis
the capsulation of tablets
i think they're asking can they also
analyze encapsulation of tablets
i'm not quite sure what you mean by the
encapsulation of tablets but
you can qc labs do analyze all kinds of
products and finished products and in
process products so if during the
capsulation there were some samples
taken for in process yes they could do
that
the qc lab no matter what they're going
to be analyzing
requires a qualified test method by the
life cycle approach
and so with that if it's a capsulation
then
the pharmaceutical technology department
and all that should have decided
what needs to be tested and why through
the quality by design
and given the qc lab the appropriate
test method for those capsulations of
tablets
thank you jana we have time for a few
more questions and i want to remind our
audience
that any questions not answered today
will be answered via email
what is the status of the usp draft
general chapter one two two zero on the
life
cycle oh that's good i'm glad you asked
that because
i i was going to say something and i
didn't um
there is a a new draft
article coming out a stimuli article and
it will be published in the usp
pharmacopoeia forum so watch for it
either the next one or the one after
that that's coming out
and so you can read that it's the usp's
latest thinking on the life cycle
approach
and you can comment on it so you can
become part of the
the writing of that you can comment on
and the usp does and they have to
we consider every single comment that is
given
and i just want to say with that the usb
has created a new general
chapter expert committee called
measurement and data quality
it's just being created right now and
it uh it will be responsible for taking
that child
chapter 12 20 to make it official so
keep watching the usp website and that
for information on that life cycle
approach
thank you jane our next audience member
wants to know how do freshers get their
experience because commonly nowadays
only experienced members get their job
well you know that goes back again to
the qc lab has to make sure that their
people
are confident and so if they're going to
hire somebody with lex
experience they can they can do that no
problem they just have to make sure that
the qc lab provides the needed training
and education that person needs
and as well it is recognized there's a
number of ways of doing that
and it is reckoned especially in 17025
the iso standard that if you're going to
have somebody with less experience
and that working on analytical procedure
they can do so but they need to do it
under the
supervision of a qualified competent
person
and so the qc labs can bring in
less experienced people as long as they
have the system
to make sure that they are competent
before they test
actual samples
thank you and regarding fda where does
the fda
reference the life cycle
ah yes yeah i mentioned a bit of that if
you
read through the guidances on the fda's
website and a couple years ago they came
up with one for the analytical
procedures
they do mention the life cycle for
example in the life cycle for
for manufacturing they state that the
analytical procedure must be suitable
for the stage of life cycle of the
manufacturing process and also
um do you uh a lot of fda guidances
mention that the risks have to be
controlled
that again is an indirect less reference
to the life cycle which is based on the
risk analysis
and they they fda guidances
also mention things like they have to be
appropriate
um significant impact all these words
that means that you the lab company have
to know
the impact and which we just saw in this
presentation when you evaluate the
uncertainty
you know the impact of each step and so
the fda is either is referencing life
cycle more directly now or if you look
in older
older guidances they actually were
saying it too at that time using
risk and significance of words like that
jane what's the materials and labor
hours cost
per test
oh that all depends on the test right
you can have a very simple loss and
ignition where you just need a furnace
at
an oven at 110 and a crucible
through to a highly
difficult biological elisa with
antibodies so
that that the cost and all that can vary
a tremendous
amount upon that test but you know
that's an interesting question because
a lot of my presentation if you went
back and you had the cost of each of
those and off when i was in the lab i
had to know the cost of each of those
steps and the cost of doing an injection
in the hplc
i knew that and then i could use that
amount
so if i were going to decrease from two
chromatograms to one because it had no
impact on the uncertainty in this
example that we had
i could i could calculate that and so
knowing the impact and the cost of the
method the uncertainty can help
very much with that so there's a whole
different
variety of tests and costs but the
uncertainty with the significance can
help you understand and
quantify that
absolutely and how difficult is it to
estimate the measurement uncertainty
ah well i don't find it difficult
at all but i have a lot of experience in
doing that
so you know what i found out is that it
really isn't that difficult and that
most
laboratories have most of the
information they need
the benefit of going through and
evaluating the uncertainty it tells them
which information they
don't have and then they can go get that
and sometimes that means you just go
back and look at old data and sometimes
it means that you have to do an
experiment or two
the vast majority of times that i go
into labs i find they do have the data
and i can estimate the uncertainty in a
couple of hours
and so with experience and with a proper
life cycle
approach it evaluates the uncertainty as
part of
part of what it does it's it's not that
hard and doesn't take that
long there is a learning curve to it
but eventually you can get much faster
thank you jane you shared a lot about
the how the materials
vary from one another how does the drug
synthesize
every time maintain quality
okay the in the example what i was
giving i was giving
i meant more of a lot of reagent in the
laboratory
sometimes the reagents are difficult to
obtain
or or they could have an impact you only
have one lot that's what i was talking
about what's the impact of changing
a lot of reagent to a test method
but here you were asking a little bit
about a lot using a lot in
a in a manufacturing so
that that is different of course but
that also happens there
so they're manufacturing and they have a
lot of some reagent a catalyst for
example
and eventually they're going to run out
of it and have to get a new lot
and mail will have to manage
that change as well
and so you know the quality by design is
being applied in manufacturing
and it's being applied in the laboratory
and so in both places you have to
know what's happening understand what's
happening
control what's happening and um
so for that understand what's happening
oh we've only got one lot
we've never changed lots we better be
careful
and control what's happening okay we're
going to test this new lot really
carefully
all right and we're going to watch the
the product the first product we make
with this new lot
and test it a little more so that's an
example of how you can look at the
different lots
uh in your manufacturing by quality by
design
thank you jane we have time for one more
question our audience member says
i am a biotechnology masters and have
experience
in biochemistry and chromatography
is there any chance of getting a job as
a qc person with my background
it sounds like yeah with that kind of
background you would have some of the
knowledge
and experience chromatography is a
commonly used technique in in quality
control labs
and so you'd have the understanding the
scientific understanding
i don't know if you have any experience
with quality control but there's a lot
of good
good courses out there on quality
control quality assurance
you could read the usp papers to start
to understand what their
that life cycle is about and
along with that additional information
um
you you uh you would have most of the
and for the the qualification you need i
would just like to refer again
the quality control labs are required to
have programs
right to select the appropriate person
and provide the training and education
that that person
needs in their lab and to assure that
person is competent before
they actually start testing real samples
jane thank you again for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any
final comments to our audience before we
close
oh thank you for that opportunity just
just one
one comment is this life cycle approach
i'm so excited about it having worked
many years in quality control labs
and i look at the life cycle approach
and they have some aspects
oh only we'd had that 20 years ago
or yes i've had that problem and this
part of the life cycle approach would
have prevented
that problem and so i encourage
everybody to read about it
and watch the usp website and provide
comment and feedback as we all go
forward in
implementing this new approach
thank you again jane for your time today
and for your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor
sartorius for underwriting today's
educational
webcast before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
i'd like to once again thank jane
weitzel for her time today and for her
important research
and thank lou lavrov and our sponsor
sartorius for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care be
safe bye